Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 18th,
2013 and a right off the bat
you should be going like, well,
this sounds a lot different than
all the other ones. Yes it does.
Um,
there's a reason for that.
The reason for it is
because the handy recorder,
h four n r by zoom,
the zoom h four n handy recorder
is a fucking diva hunk of shit.
Fuck that recorder. And it's
nonexistent. Digital ass.
I've had more Goddamn fucking problems
with this thing. First of all,
they give you a fucking memory card.
We can record like just over a podcast.
So every fucking God damn week
I start the podcast.
If I forgot your race, the
last one, I have a problem.
And I know what you guys are thinking.
Well Bill,
why don't you buy a new fucking
memory card while I'm an asshole?
Okay.
Committedly I'm an asshole. But you
know what I did? You know what I did?
People get swirl. Fucking Billy
red faced went the other day.
Well, I went to the wrong place first,
but then they told me where to go.
And then I went and I bought
a fucking memory card,
some 60 fucking four gig memory card.
I stick it in.
This thing's fucking little slot there.
Turned it on.
It says, do you want to format
the card? Why? Yes, I would.
Handy fucking recorder of h
four n Zoom Douche, right?
How child does,
she says right now,
try not to be mad at an inanimate
object as Joe de Rosa says.
Um, but I am. So I put it in there
and it says error can't do it.
And then I go on the internet wasting
more fucking time of my life. Oh,
you technology douche bags out there.
Who just think that this stuff
makes your life easier. It doesn't,
it doesn't cause it's constantly
fucking breaking down.
And then I got to go on the Internet
and I got to try and figure out what the
hell's going on, do you know, shifting
through all this, this horse shit.
And, uh, I found something and I followed
it to the t and it still says it's,
it's that there's a problem.
So what do I have to do?
I'm in New York City right now,
by the way,
I'm going to have to somehow
get in touch with Bobby Kelly
and I'm going to flip the
fuck out screaming about
tech. This is what happens.
Is this help Bobby Kelly helps you
with technology. I call him up.
I immediately go on a rant about
technology and the banking system.
He sits back and relaxes,
you know,
probably has the phone like 20 feet
from his ear. And when I'm done ranting,
you know,
he'll just sit there and be like,
I did what's a product game? But
what do you, what do you have?
And I'll make this fucking piece of shit,
so fuck if it did do,
is that a piece of shit? Dude is actually,
I've had that thing is fucking great.
I
get the new one, it's fucking
wireless. Um, and then he talks to me,
fucking throw it,
you know?
And what kills me is I like to think
that I'm just as smart as Robert Kelly,
but evidently I'm not,
he never comes to me for help,
but I think that's cause he's,
he's afraid.
He's afraid of the feelings
that he has for me.
So anyways, I don't even know
how to adjust these levels.
I hope I'm not blowing out
you fucking ear drums here.
MMM.
Anyways,
you know what was funny about all of
this once I was going to make fun of this
kid who was having problems
downloading my special,
you know, and this is basically, you know,
fortunately I've had a nice steady stream
of people downloading my special and
I'm,
I swear to God for every like 50 75
people that downloaded successfully,
there'll be one person that has a problem.
I get right back to them. You know,
usually that day,
if not within two to three days,
I get back to them as soon as I can.
We get them a new link and they
get the special. All right.
And I've actually learned a lot about
myself reading some of these emails
because the amount of people
who immediately assume
that they're getting fucked let
basically that I'm fucking them over.
Which you know, like I, I basic,
I announced that I have this special to
download for $5 and once I get your $5,
my game plan is there really is no link.
Okay.
Like how long can I
realistically get away with that?
Maybe for a week before all
you guys talk to each other,
just like there's no link.
He's just stealing $5 from us.
At which point I would become the
biggest douche on the Internet and no one
would come to my shows and I would
go back to sleeping on a futon.
So why would I do that?
But what cracks me up is I
understand the anger as you can tell.
I'm sure there's somebody out there who
has a zoom h four n handy recorder and
knows exactly,
you know what to fucking buttons to hit.
And my whole world would be perfect.
MMM.
I have to tell you, it is an
unbelievably confusing fucking device.
This is definitely,
this has to be some pro level shit cause
they did not dumb it down for someone
like myself. So anyways,
getting back to the, um,
getting back to the, uh, the downloads.
Okay. If you are having problems, okay,
the link does work. Okay. Admittedly,
a couple times there has been a
glitch on our end and we go out,
we fix it immediately.
You will get a link.
I'm not trying to fuck
you over if you for,
if you are just like,
well it didn't work the first time
and I don't feel like waiting.
I want my $5 back. I will, I will
absolutely refund your money.
You're not going to get fucked.
Okay.
You're not going to get
fucked out of your money. You,
they're going to get the special. Are
you going to get your $5 back? So,
mmm.
I Dunno.
But I've actually learned a lot about
myself watching people having meltdowns
about these things. This one
kid wrote me today, he goes,
I would like my money back from my
purchase of your special on January 25th,
2013. I never had a chance to see this
special and I am deeply outraged by the
horrible quality of your customer service.
Please return my $5 to
my checking account.
Immediately sound like Jesus Christ did
I miss this guy. So I look up his email.
It's fucking hilarious. I've already
talked to the guy three times.
He got the initial link and we sent them
to more links and he hasn't been able
to download it. Okay. I
got back to him every time,
either that day or within 24 hours
and now he asked for his $5 back and
I gave it back to him within like 45
minutes to him asking for, all right,
I understand you're upset or dude,
but how was that horrible
customer service?
Now if you want to say it's a horrible
link, you know, that's one thing.
My customer service,
I'm going to pat myself on the backyard.
I think it's pretty fucking good. I
wouldn't say it's outstanding. All right.
I'm not trying to get trashed by other
consumers are going to send me emails,
but I'm just saying all right.
Sometimes it does take me like three
days to get back to you. But you know,
I've running a mom and pop operation here.
I got to fly to fucking uh,
east bumped fucks to do is
show, you know, that day,
maybe I'm not looking at my emails,
but I will get back to all right?
And then a whole,
there's been thousands of people,
thank God who downloaded
my special successfully. So
the link is fine. All right.
I sent the guy let it
back. I told him, I said,
till we got back to you every time you
emailed us and I just gave you $5 back.
How was that horrible customer service?
I don't know what to tell you.
What more am I supposed to do?
Fly to where you live and stare
at your computer with your,
God knows I can't figure it out.
This guys deeply outraged over $5.
Thank God my special wasn't 20 bucks.
Like I wasn't selling
like a hard copy of it.
This guy probably hunt
me down and shoot me. Oh,
speaking of shooting people,
how about that fucking Cyborg allegedly
shot his woman through the fucking
bathroom door. Jesus Christ. Huh?
What a fucking creepy story
that is. You know, it's funny,
as I was sitting here today
flipping out about the zoom h four,
this is like the anti commercial
for this thing, h four and recorder,
if you're stupid, please do not buy this
thing because you'll end up like me.
And I'm really trying to,
uh,
it's rosy used to have this joke about
him flipping out at a laptop and somebody
saw him and said, hey, that's an inanimate
object. You're better than that. But Bob,
blah, blah blah. So I, I,
for some last night I was flipping
about stepping out about how my internet
sucks in New York and how, because I
was so mad at the Internet connection,
I actually had the urge to grab my laptop,
a completely innocent bystander and just
fucking like sort of like a combination
of a Frisbee in a disgust and I
wanted to throw it through my window
rather than using my brain
and sitting down, um,
or maybe,
uh,
just solving the problem.
Maybe just calling up and canceling the
wireless service and getting that little
fucking, uh, what do you call it?
The Internet stokey that you can
stick into the side of your computer.
So you have internet everywhere.
That Bobby Kelly shit dead
like an internet everywhere.
I stick the stick in. I put
on my little ear piece, dude,
it's all fucking wireless.
It orders me a sandwich.
Yeah. Um, anyways,
the fuck was I talking about, you
know that guy actually I, I made,
I made a bad move the other day.
I asked,
I called Bobby Kelly up and I
told them I needed a new printer
and you kick someone like me cannot talk
to a guy like on Bobby Kelly's level of
technology. Okay. Because all of
my shit is from like, you know,
three presidents ago. All
right. I don't like technology.
Um, as far as I don't
like new technology. Okay.
I would be happy.
I was happy with,
my life was in the 80s and I didn't
have a laptop or cell phone. I was fine.
I don't know about you guys,
but I was eating three times a day.
I had a roof over my head,
you know,
I had a carburetor,
I had no fuel injection and I was fine.
My car couldn't talk to me.
I didn't have any GPS Cya. Oh, I had
a map. It's not like an old man here,
but my life was fine
when I say I don't like technologies for
all the Douche bags already firing up
your email. Really would you like
to go back to the caveman days?
You know what I'm saying? Past a certain
point, the shit hasn't been helping me.
Okay.
Right up to cure polio and penicillin
right there. We should have,
we should just walked away
from the Black Jack Table.
We should have left it at that,
you know,
and then all we would have had to have
done is just dealt with the population
problem in that you just keep it in check.
Okay.
You get one of these mathematical
fucking nerds, God bless him.
And we just have a number of that.
We will not go beyond.
Okay. And, and you know, in
a, in an imperfect world, um,
everybody could join hands and we would
all work together and there would be no
countries,
but that's not the way it is
because the sociopath hungry sociopaths
and fucking religious psychopaths.
Yeah.
Okay. If you could eliminate those two
people, those two groups of people,
you know,
people who take the Hocus pocus shit too
seriously and then those, those fucking,
yeah,
those, those people who will do
anything. We'll fucking do anything.
You know,
the only feeling they feel as the Russia
of putting their foot on somebody's
neck. If you could just get
rid of those two people.
I was kid who we'd look at us,
look at us on the Internet.
There's a wave of trash.
Each other probably still
wouldn't work, but whatever.
This is my utopia.
I think we should have tapped
out somewhere around like, um,
I dunno, when did the first
Atari come out? You've got
to have video games, right?
Asteroids with spray and you guys,
whatever, you get bored with it.
But yeah, they'd come up with a new
asteroids maybe that maybe the, the,
the ship would be shaped like a square.
Maybe the rocks were like hexagon.
No rocks where hexagons.
Well you just make the space spaceship,
the shape of the asteroids and then the
asteroids, the shape of the space ship,
new spaceship shaped asteroids and we all,
we all would have been excited cause we
didn't know any better because we didn't
know there was a bad, a battlefield earth
part for whatever the fuck it's called.
Have you video guys are doing there?
I don't even want to say it's one even
so Bobby tells me to get this fucking,
I call up Bobby Kelly who Bobby is like,
you know when I go to Bob's
pops apartment or whatever,
it's like walking in my world. It's like
walking like nine years into the future.
You don't remember when it Yankee
Stadium first came out and they were all
arrogant going,
we have 2013 technology in 2009
and when they said that shit,
which really was the dumbest thing
ever, it's like no. If you had,
you have 2009 technology that is not
going to be available to a nerd like me.
Not a nerd,
a loser like me until 2013 you're really
just sort of rubbing it in my face.
All right.
Of course I'll Yankee fans safe,
but oh,
they got tech doll with chief
problem of future Derek Jeter,
right?
Oh, it's your fucking Yankee Jersey
that you can't button anymore.
MMM.
Anyways, what am I talking
about here? Oh, so Bobby,
Bobby's like nine years in the future
compared to me. So he gets me this.
I get this fucking thing right?
Fucking wireless did everything. Bobby
has has to be wireless, you know,
it's fucking where they stayed. I
think I can drive in a cat, dude.
And I just think of something.
It's, it's wired into my brain.
A little heavy. It
prints it out, dude. Um,
so I get this thing, of course,
this fucking goddamn thing.
I've probably used it 20 times, 17 times.
I've had a fucking problem with it.
One time for no reason.
I would,
I would hit print and it would go through
the entire stack of paper that I had
printing, nothing, just printing
hell high. He had whole hat,
he had whole hat and I'm going, what
the fuck's going on? [inaudible] he had.
Right. And then finally the
last two pages, it would
just print a bunch of code.
And you know,
I don't give a fuck.
Just at some point in
that five minute exercise,
fucking print when I've tried to print,
never does it.
So then I got called Bobby up.
Bob, this fucking predecessor did.
It doesn't set date.
What's, just tell me what,
go into properties or whatever.
Click on the apple gate.
Okay.
And I'm on the phone for like 45 minutes.
I liked my old printer.
It had a wire,
it was tethered to reality and I plugged
it into my fucking laptop. You know,
I like that real shit. And I'm
like, it's in the air, man.
I don't know what's going on. I can't
figure that shit out. So anyways,
I don't know what the fuck are
we even talking about here?
I wonder what am I really saying? Why
can't it stuff be easy? Why can't stuff,
what I really want is for nothing to
change so I don't have to learn anything
new. I think that's what I'm
really trying to say here. MMM.
I don't know. I'm going to talk about New
York City here in second. Yeah. Once I,
uh,
let's do a couple of
advertisements really quickly.
I can get Jesus.
Oh,
Jesus then rubs with tonight.
Oh, no. You know what?
I'm actually going out to Hasbrook
heights. We want to benefit. All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Are you waiting for the perfect
time to start your dream business?
It's now legal zoom,
the official sponsor of National Start
Your Business month once you to get, uh,
get your business started right.
Whether you're setting up an LLC, LLC,
an s Corp Sole Proprietor
to ship or nonprofit legal
zoom takes care of you from
start to finish.
The award winning service was developed
by the best legal minds in the country
and every business gets
personalized attention.
That's why over 90% of
legal zoom customers would
recommend the service to their
family.
You'll be in good company,
three dozen companies in the inc 500
list for started through legal zoom.
Uh, it's national starch or business
months to start your business right
now@legalzoom.com.
Legalzoom is not a law form and provide
self health services at your specific
direction. In other words, when you're
having problems, get in touch with them.
They've got a legal staff that
will help you through it anyways,
but there's so much more now.
Every LLC and incorporation
package includes easy to use,
business accounting software, uh,
$269 value for absolutely free.
Be sure to enter Berg, B U R R in
the referral box at the checkout.
It starts your business,
protect your family and safeguard your
assets@legalzoom.com today are actually,
um,
saw back in New York City right now.
I immediately went from absolute paradise
as far as weather goes, you know,
not as far as population and
breathable air drinkable water,
but the weather's great.
And I came in in New York and uh,
you know, I actually really
fucking enjoy cold weather. And,
um, the only thing that sucks
was it snowed like five days ago.
So when it first snows,
it's, it's beautiful.
It's like a newborn baby. Just gorgeous.
Everywhere you go, looks like a postcard,
but you know, three, four days later
it's just a, you know, you think you're,
you're an eastern fucking Europe and
that's what it looks like right now. Uh,
it's kind of a nice sunny day, but
I gotta be honest with you. Um,
if you're past the age of 40 and
you're still dealing with winters,
I just want you to know that there
are options. You know what? No, no.
You know what,
keep,
keep living in the last thing when he was
more fucking people. Ellen, it's great.
You know, you get the four seasons, you
know, one and a half of them are nice.
I like it.
You know what I like to change of seasons.
Do you have any idea what it's like to
just fucking just wake up every day and
the weather is awesome. It's awesome.
And I know what he's [inaudible], dude,
you've got to lose your edge. That's
how fucked up east coast people are.
We're afraid that we're
going to lose our anger.
Hey, you're going to lose your
edge. He ate. But be careful.
You might end up being happy.
You might end up, uh, you know,
enjoying your life. Go easy. Now. I mean,
when I first moved out to la the first
time I was out there when I hated it and
this didn't seem right and I fought it
so hard to not to try and not enjoy it,
but I did.
I played a roller hockey on the day of
the Superbowl in shorts and a tee shirt
in this parking garage. It's the
90s. Okay, let's go fuck yourself.
And it was roller hockey. I wasn't skating
down the boardwalk in a fanny pack,
but, uh, if footage of me
doing that does surface,
I would love to say that it was
somehow Photoshop for the record.
I never had a fanny pack,
but not because, um,
I didn't like him.
I just found I just,
okay.
I wanted pockets. I just, I don't
like shit on me, you know what I mean?
I just,
I don't like it.
Then it makes you a waste sweaty that
wherever the fanny is fanny pack a pack is
on the fanny pack that's going to get all
sweaty. I don't fucking like, you know,
I used to put the money in my sock
and then my keys and my other songs.
I used to be that guy, you know. Anyways,
so I'm playing roller hockey
at the top of his fucking uh,
uh, parking garage. The
houses, me, Dane Cook,
Rick Dolly and Pete coming right for
two, one, two fucking psycho gay.
We had where it was like zero to zero
and we were all such competitive maniacs.
This is back before Tiva.
We almost missed the beginning of the
Superbowl because we had to play until
somebody one or maybe it was one to one.
You know,
when you don't have that official
clock or anything, it was foods,
the fucking shit. And we will laugh
and just go like, my buddy was going,
who loved La. I was like,
dude, we're gonna watch the
Superbowl. How nuts is this?
Everybody back east is freezing their
fucking balls off route here in the sun.
Play roller hockey on top
of this parking structure,
hoping the security doesn't come up here.
And I was buying into that whole, um,
and losing my edge. Man,
I'm not going to be funny,
but meanwhile la is one of the most
difficult cities I've ever had to live in
just as far as getting from point a to
point B and also trying to keep you your
head screwed on because um,
it's a fun place when you're working.
That's all I can tell you
when you're not working. Uh,
and if you are out there right
now and you're struggling,
I definitely don't be
afraid to have a hobby.
Don't be afraid to have something that
you can actually fucking look forward to
that will actually help you. You know,
some of these psychos out there that 24,
seven, I gotta be about the
business. Hey, you want to a, hey,
here's a free cupcake. Would you like a
cupcake? And I am like, can I expect him?
You got to get the skip them.
Who turns down a free cupcake has kind
of greed when man to another man. Huh?
Um, anyway, so I'm back
here in New York and uh,
I dunno, it's weird. I love New
York, but I just don't miss it.
I always thought I would miss it, but
I don't miss it. I woke up a fucking,
God knows what time this morning,
a holiday, backyard area.
It is president's Day of
some shit and some assholes.
It's got his fucking stereo on like two
floors down. One of those Douche bags.
Um, status is probably, music is my life.
Music is the air.
I believe.
Something trite that they're trying to
make original and whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
life equals music is fucking
play in his God. Damn.
I'm going to say stereo because I don't
know what the kids call into explaining
his fucking stereo from two floors down.
I'm hearing this guy the baseline
of his ship and you know, I just,
I just don't miss it.
This is basically,
I live in a big house with
like, you know, 700 strangers.
I got a smelly a food. I got to
hear their arguments. You know,
you always got some sorta
is always somebody you know,
some old person who's been living there
since like the fucking sixties who's
paid $3 a month in rent and you
walk by their fucking place.
Everybody's making some sort of Goulash
and the combination of that and the
fucking heater that they can adjust
for some reason and it's 9,000 degrees.
He combination of that and smelling that
Goulash and had douche play his stereo.
I just, I don't fucking miss it. Then
I got to walk out, look at dirty snow.
I've had it. I was like,
Oh yeah, I remember this.
And then there's that when it's getting
spring in New York was beautiful.
Fall in New York is great summers.
Cool for about two seconds
before the humidity comes
in. All the fucking crooked,
rich [inaudible] slash.
Celebrities,
they all go out to the Hamptons to go
fucking air off their balls and we got to
sit here taking the goddamned subway
and all office. It's the worst,
the fucking worst. So, um, uh,
I think I'm just grumpy.
I still liked New York,
but it was kind of disturbing how
much I'm sitting here going like, hey,
this is a, this is really
no way to live. You know,
I said this before in New
York. It's for young people,
you know, up to about 35, 36.
You can have a great fucking time. Those
last four years is just sliding into 40.
Don't fight that feeling that says,
hey,
why don't we get out of here and live like
a human being, you know, fuck the two,
one, two area code. You can visit it,
drop in and visit it. Go out to jersey,
go to upstate New York, whatever the
fuck in Westchester. It yourself,
a house and a driveway.
All right.
The only time you smelled Goulash,
if yours is, if you're making it,
you're human being deserve to
live like one, uh, anyways,
plowing ahead here. Uh, on the
podcast, where am I up to here?
This is oddly cruising right along, but
I can't find the numbers for 25 minutes.
Was it wrong? Um, I had
a great week this week,
this past week.
I've got to do the Conan O'brien show.
We'll have the link for that up on,
uh,
up on a Monday morning podcast page.
Um,
Conan's great. You know,
when you get going,
he chimes in and once you get
going and just let you go.
He's totally old school and if he
thinks you're funny, he laughs. It's a,
it really is that old
school Johnny Carson style.
And uh,
I'm getting more and more comfortable
doing those panel things and I get a real
kick out of doing it because
that was sort of, that was,
that's sort of a lost art amongst
comedians just for the simple fact that we
haven't gotten the opportunities to do it.
Where back in the day,
I guess there was less opportunities.
Maybe it balances out the fact of the day.
Johnny Carson, you know, he had his go to,
he would have comics on and they,
they weren't promoting anything.
He would just have them on because
they were, they were a great guest.
They come on and he knew that
they were going to hit a home run.
MMM.
And I used to grow up watching these
guys, David Brenner, George Gobel, um,
all these guys.
And I would,
I would be psyched when they were
on and they'd come on Buddy Hackett,
they just come on and tell stories.
They weren't promoting anything.
They were just hilarious.
And he'd watched Johnny laughing his
ass off and it went right through
Letterman. Leno, uh, are some of
the other guys I saw. But then,
I dunno,
once this talk show stuff became so
well back then, he was the only
game in town. So there wasn't,
it's not the way it is now
where there's like 20 shows.
I'll try and get this tape a piece
of the same pie. But anyways,
uh,
there was something,
I always wanted him to get good at it.
So I was really sucked
at my, it went well, uh,
this past Monday. It's just something
that I, I want to get better at. And,
uh, I just, I dunno,
it was just like the cool thing that
for awhile comics just really weren't
getting that opportunity
or not enough of them.
We're getting that opportunity
and it was frustrating.
I'm not saying it's all
actors and all guests,
but to sit there at home
and watch people coming out,
we put and tell the fucking story.
But they had a giant movie,
which I understand they got to
promote the giant movie. I Dunno.
I just would always look at
that and be like, you know,
it would be great right now.
Now that that person Kinda did only okay.
And the hosts had to work their ass
off to help them through the segment.
If you just had a comment,
come on, tell some stories,
and the host could take a
little fucking breather. Uh,
it's just great. I Dunno. It's just great
that Conan is doing that type of thing.
MMM.
And you know, it was funny. As
a comic you always like, man,
I want to do those things,
those five minutes sets.
It's like playing Russian roulette.
I'd rather just go out and you just to
watch somebody do panel and you think
it's fucking easy and then all of a
sudden you had have to do panel and you're
like, oh my God, what if I'm
sitting there bombing? Uh,
I had a nice panic attack before it
went out there right before when I was
standing behind the curtain. I
was just like that, why am I here?
I have nothing to talk about.
Blah Blah Blah. But uh,
fortunately it worked out. I did that.
And then I have an episode of that show,
the new girl coming up,
I'll let you guys know.
I finally decided I'm actually going to
tell you what I'm doing as opposed to
keep,
I think I've worn out that a
bleed joke at this point.
And I actually got to work with
Nick Kroll, who I tell you,
that guy was one of the silliest,
funniest motherfuckers I ever worked with.
The whole cast was awesome.
And,
but nit for all that dude
is out of his fucking mind.
And uh, I don't think I've
laughed that hard. You know,
it's a one camera shoot. So you're
doing like 12 hour days and it's like,
uh, you like a Zombie. You know?
I actually still like doing those things.
I started to understand why my
dog sleeps all day, you know?
And it's basically because he has nothing
to fucking do. She has nothing to do.
And if you have nothing to do
with your brain's just like okay,
we don't have to think we're just going
to shut this down and you fall asleep.
And that's what was happening to me.
I was nodding off.
Cause like when you're shooting it,
it's the most exciting fucking thing ever.
And you feel like you could run a marathon
then I would turn it around or you're
not in this next one,
you just sit down,
there's nothing to do.
Everything else is being handled and
you're just sitting there waiting for that
to tell you where to stand to say
the stuff that they wrote. Right.
And in that time you just fucking
not off like a fucking dog.
Um, but anyways, I'm telling you man,
check out the Kroll show.
I got to hear and what I really
want to hide this show because I,
I think this guys,
I think he's absolutely fucking brilliant.
Um,
come on.
I'm the worst. I think it's on Wednesdays.
What happened? Oh, I know what happened.
I had it up there and then my fucking
piece of shit reported in work or
another reality that recorded that works.
But I can't figure out
how it works on a separate
row show you go call me central.com.
Nick Kroll show is new episodes
Wednesday at 10 39 30 central on,
uh,
on a comedy central.
He's absolutely fucking hilarious.
Uh,
and I really hope that show continues to
be a hit. Anyways. All right, there's the,
there's the hype to the week.
Let's get back to the podcast.
Hell that I want to talk
about. Oh, that meteor.
I'll fuck you.
Do you guys see some of the footage?
People got that thing just
appearing out of the sky.
Now there's somebody, somebody's going
to give me shit about technology. There
were back in the day,
you had no idea it was even coming and
you would just out there a little fucked
up a date, but the, but dab that through
doing whatever the fuck he did back then.
Right. And all of a sudden this thing just
comes out of the sky. I mean, honestly,
if that thing falls into your house,
she had dead.
But I was amazed at the amount of people,
right. Who are out driving around. Um,
I was driving around,
I would've looked like ray Liotta in
the second half of good fellas when he's
all coked up looking for that helicopter.
That would have been me trying
to get my ass to a shelter. Uh,
is it, is it agreed upon at this
point that that's how the dinosaurs
died off? Was that a giant media
or is that still just a theory?
Even though they probably found the
crater and proved it, but the fucking old,
the AVH people refuse to
believe it because somehow
that fucks with the Adam and
Eve story.
How exactly has the church
worked in dinosaurs and all that.
Adam and eve,
they were together and they were
living in a paradise and uh,
they started the human race.
Forget about the incestuous
consequences of that math.
We'll just say it was those two and they
were both white yet somehow they was
all these different races of people.
Uh,
I don't even know if
that even makes sense.
How do different races and people come
about? You know what's funny that's like,
that's a great question to ask when
you're in a bar with someone with no
scientific or is it genetics?
Is that the word?
Maybe it just ask someone as dumb as
me. People are like, Oh, you know, uh,
it's just shit.
I heard in bars like when I was growing
up that like people in Africa were,
uh, or Africans, I guess, if that's
an easier way to say it. I went,
people in Africa instead of
say Africans the same way.
Everybody who plays basketball now says
the game of basketball rather than just
saying basketball,
you know what,
I'm out there playing the
game of basketball. You know,
we started that Michael Jordan.
Somebody said it to him and he liked it
as far as I can tell them as far as my,
by watching ESPN and the NBA on Chibe Ash,
I think he was the first guy.
He's the guy who made it cool to say that
the game of basketball and these guys
all grow up watching Michael
Jordan and they keep saying,
hearing him say the game of basketball.
Now all these motherfuckers,
they keep saying the game of basketball.
It's like this Yoda ship. You know?
I mean I,
I really don't,
I can't really do a reference to Yoda
cause I don't see that movie a couple of
times.
But I've seen a zillion comic Stewart
where you put the shift that usually comes
last first. You know,
I don't fucking know,
but I'm really sick of hearing people
talk about the game of basketball.
But I am loving Lebron James saying that
he has the ability to become the best
ever.
You know,
I am loving that he's saying that it's
just great to hear a guy who's going to
try and go for that type of thing.
And just the fact that he kind of used
to get a little tight at the end of the
game. He's got, he's all the broadsoft
grown up, you know? And plus,
because I hate Laker fans and I hate
Coby Bryant. I don't hate him personally,
but you know, I just hate
all the Oh, by the way,
how's that whole Magic Bryant
Shit work it out for you. Huh?
It's he still passing the ball.
How many times you,
you fucking Laker fans going to fall for
that shit. He's turned over a new leaf.
He's actually going to work with
the rest of the teeth. You know,
you guys keep coming back like
a battered fucking wife though.
Maybe it won't hit me this
time. What? Quack? Uh,
anyways,
there's nothing more a Celtic fans enjoys
more than watching Colby try and go
for 60 points. Keeps you from Colby.
Three guys on you. You got it.
Turn around jumper,
take it,
get your 40 to get your 42 points.
Colby all day,
all day. Um, anyways,
fuck. Am I going here? Uh,
sh now getting all fucking freaked
out about this stupid thing.
Did I put that I put the wrong car
then and then I messed up that I,
if you put the wrong party and the thing
does that, does that mess up the uh,
the brain on the thing?
Is that too technical a question?
Hey, you know, it's funny,
I sent out a tweet for, uh,
this guy and I was really
only for guitar players only,
but, um, just how, I don't
know the names of Shit.
This guy is going off on people who
don't know the different names of good,
good people, but what do you have a
maple neck or a rosewood neck? Hey,
the guy's going to be dumb motherfucker.
It, everybody's got a maple neck.
Oh,
both these next or maple.
The fretboard fret board is Rosewood.
You've got to Rosewood Fret board,
not a neck. You dumb mother fucker.
And he's just sitting here going off
and he ends with the greatest. He goes,
you know, half the people,
if you just played,
you could tar half as much as you bitch.
You might be worth a fuck on the guitar.
I Dunno. It's tremendous. So anyways,
you probably like go. Hey Bill,
what are you doing? What
are you doing back in, uh,
in, uh, New York City.
I am a, I am back here.
I'm doing a couple of benefits tonight.
I'm at bananas in Hasbrouck Heights,
uh, doing a benefit for a
buddy of mine's wife, uh,
who's sick right now,
but he's turning the corner and then
Tuesday night we're going to have the,
uh, the big Patrice O'Neil
benefit slash sendoff.
We're finally going to send them off,
right man.
Like if this thing has been a long time
coming, it's going to be an insane night.
And uh,
I'm really psyched to see all the
guys who are going to be there and uh,
it's definitely a good thing. And a,
there you go. That's why I'm here.
And then I'm going to go up to Boston
on Wednesday, going up to the Wilbur,
my big, uh, of course the Bruins are
out of town. They weren't in town.
I've been watching fucking
show, but um, all right.
Is it me or is it the podcast kind
of fucking went downhill, hasn't it?
It's Kinda, it's Kinda
dipped a little, let's,
let's get this back to get this back
on track. So fucking Versie knows.
And I'm going to be in
Hasbrouck heights than nights.
So you know what he tells me
he wants to go to white castle.
All right? You get a bunch of little
white castle burgers in a vanilla shake.
It goes, it's going to be epic.
And I'm not going to lie to you,
I'm not gonna to say that that is a great,
but the fact that verse,
He makes fun of New Jersey,
you know,
and this and this,
going to white castle and getting a
vanilla shake is his idea of a great night
out. I mean, Paul Versey, he's so jersey,
his last name rhymes with it.
You know,
he's talking about going to this place,
like it's going to be a steakhouse.
And this is the thing, I'm white trash
too because I'm beyond excited to,
I want to fire down as many of
those burgers is quickly as I can.
And the key is you got to eat them really
fast before your body ruins the fun
telling you to please stop doing it.
So if you're coming out to
bananas, Hasbrouck Heights
tonight, and about eight,
nine minutes into my set, despite the
fact I'm leading on the mic stand,
but I'm inexplicably sweating,
it's not because I'm nervous,
it's going to be my body.
Trying to is beginning to eliminate
the 9,000 calories of a trans fats.
I just put my body, you know,
every once in a while you get,
you've got to keep your body honest.
You know, I'm starting off great today.
I had a banana for breakfast.
I'm going to have an apple as a snack
and amount of a giant fucking salad,
old twinkle toes here, um, for
lunch. And then I'm throwing down.
That's how I do it. That's
my balanced diet. All right?
I eat like I teach yoga for
the first half of the day,
and John Wayne from five o'clock on,
hey, it's better than what I used to
do. I used to start off, you know,
bacon and eggs and all that type of stuff.
Uh,
I know there's gonna be some people
out there going, hey, you know,
there's nothing wrong with bacon and eggs.
I'm not saying there is all right,
but you know,
listen for all you guys out there who
eat red meat and you want to say how you
know all the, the, the good
things about it and everything,
but I'm right there with you.
I love eating a fucking steak,
okay?
I drive by a pasture and I have all I can
do to not get out of the car and start
nine on some cow's neck. All right?
Fucking disgusting. But it's true.
But look,
fuck all these diet books.
Go out and eat a giant goddamn salad.
Don't drown in addressing.
All right?
Go with the Balsamic vinegarette do that
three days in a row and you watch how
well your body
operates,
okay?
You will be a finely tuned machine and
you can continue with your fucking chops
and all that crap. Just eating one
giant leafy Greens. Valid a day.
I'm telling you talent. And not
only that, it kind of, you know,
quells that sugar salt fucking arm wrestle
thing that you're doing the whole day.
It's really been helping me out and I
don't have to work out as much and I think
that that's uh, that's really
the game plan, isn't it?
Don't you want to be in shape and
not really have to work out? Right.
Did I just become some sort of a,
I should have a headset on
right now and like doing that,
that little warmup side decide to
step that they do. Okay. Everybody,
thanks for coming out here. We've
got to have a great workout. Okay,
let me just start, put your arms out to
the side of this. Make little circles.
Here we go. Then you know everybody,
and I'm still doing little side to side.
I try to eat one salad every day.
I start breathing into that fucking
Janet Jackson headset. Uh, all
right, what do we got here?
We've got one more advertising to hear.
Oh, the one you guys are all waiting for.
stamps.com everybody.
If you're sick of going to the post office
and you'd like to do everything that
you could do with the post
office within your own home,
you need to be go be going to be going
to stamps.com stamps.com you can buy and
print official us postage
for any letter or package.
Using your own computer or printer gives
me pick up stamps.com we'll send you a
digital scale,
calculates the exact amount of postage
you need for any class of male.
Then you just hand your mail to the
mailman dropping in a mailbox or can
schedule a free package pickup using
stamps.com you'll never have to deal with
bad weather again to send
out letters and packages. Um,
I use stamps.com to send all my DVDs
to all my road gigs. It has worked.
I have never had a problem right now.
Use My last name bur bur
for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer
includes a digital scale and up to $55 in
free postage. Uh, don't wait.
Go to stamps.com and click
on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type
in burpee.
You are that stamps.com enter
Berg are saving you time,
saving you time. Um, back to the uh,
back to the podcast. Let's get to
some questions or shall we? Shall We?
Shall we do this? All right. Go
fucked up world uncle bill for
Elica you guys every week people,
you guys are coming up with new different
ways to say my name. Billion. Belford
it'll be red face.
They'll be fat face dilly bag of donuts.
Anyways, why don't we all,
when are we all going to vote?
A Joe Schmoe in as president.
Just any other guy than someone who's
got this is like classic ballroom talk.
Just any other, any guy other
than someone who's got a payback,
some corporation of bank that got
them there in the first place.
I understand you usually
tackle relationship advice
in a way this pertains to
our relationship with this, with our
country. No Dude, I would love to,
I would love to answer conspiracy theory
shit. The only reason why I, you know,
what it is, is people listen
every week and they start,
I should start throwing out more
topics through conspiracy theory.
I'll always do the relationship stuff.
You want to talk sports,
anything you want to talk about.
Um,
I will answer the questions and all
you guys have to realize is I am not a
fucking expert and I do not
know what I'm talking about.
All I'm trying to do is make you laugh
and make you drive to work a little
shorter. That's all I'm doing
here. All right. Anyways, he says,
in a way, this pertains to our
relationship with our country.
Every day we hear our bags and
governments getting away with crazy shit.
It's exhausting. I want to shut
down, ignore and ignore it all,
but that's what they want. Am I stopped
and I am a stubborn cunt, so fuck them.
What do we do? Thanks.
Frustrated the son of a bitch.
Um, all right. When are we going?
When are we going to vote a
Joe Schmo in for president?
That's never going to happen.
It's impossible to do.
We would all have to get organized and
the organ to organization to be able to
do that.
Um,
they would figure out that we were doing
it and then they would figure out who
was leading it and then that person would,
um,
somehow get shot by a lone gunman alone,
crazed gunman,
acer hand, Sir hand and Eddie, Eddie, you
know, somebody with a crazy fucking name,
you know.
Um,
and let's just say for the,
for the sake of argument that we
actually all got together secretively and
nobody found out and we actually voted
a Joe Schmo and for president, uh,
nobody would work with them.
No one would work with them.
And He,
and it would be in every politician's
best interest to have that guy have the
worst presidency ever. So they could all
look at the American people and be like,
see what happens with the adult
vote Democrat or Republican?
They would just do that. I mean,
they don't even work with each other.
If a republican gets in as
president and the house, Ooh,
I'm getting in over my head house, is that
what it's called? If that's democratic,
they won't work with that guy.
They spend every waking moment trying to
fuck over whatever that guy's trying to
do. It's childish and vice
versa if I see versus are there.
So they don't even work with each other.
Forget about some Joe Schmo
coming in as president. Um,
I would say what you have
to do is a ground up thing.
I would try to vote for the most honest
person you could as a local town.
Selectman is a regional,
one of the,
then they have like sort of regional
senators and then state senators and then
like senators at a federal level.
I don't think,
I honestly don't think
that there is a way.
Uh,
you know what it'd be like.
It's like you have a leaky faucet.
It all you're trying to do is buy more
paper towels and keep wiping up the water
and you're never dealing with the
leaky faucet. Okay. This shit is,
it's how do I, how do I, how do
I put this in my own moronic way?
All right.
I've done a lot of people's shows,
you know,
little acting thing here
or a fucking podcast here,
a big time shows at this point. I've done
that stuff and this is what I've found.
If the person at the top is a good shit,
everybody,
everybody's a good shit.
Everybody's a good, you know,
if the person at the top is not an
egomaniac and not acting like an asshole,
a fucking diva,
everybody falls in line because you can't
act like an asshole. It's like, well,
this guy is making more money than all of
us and he's, he's treating people well.
You know,
if I start acting like a dick,
then it's just going to expose
me as being a dick. All right?
But if the person at the
top is a cunt, it, you know,
and it's just been an
unbelievable pain in the ass.
You know,
it's that leadership thing.
It just rolls downhill and
everybody acts that way. The problem
okay
with the world is it's a fuck or
be fucked system that we have.
Okay.
All right.
And it's like it starts at the top with
the fuck over and they pass that on to
the next level and it's hot potato.
You're trying to pass the fuck over
on,
you know what I mean?
And once you get in the game,
you end up just doing shit.
You don't even want to do.
You just have to do it because
that's how the game is played.
It's the whole bringing a
knife to a gunfight. You
can't do it. It's a gun fight.
You got to get a gun. And
I don't know how, I don't,
I honestly don't think the only way to
change it is for basically one of these
asteroids has to hit the earth and we
have to be wiped out like the fucking
dinosaurs and it has to start
over again. You know, because
we are flawed. That's all I can say. Yeah,
we're flawed just in general.
Even if you,
even if you weren't able to
eliminate sociopath, just in general,
we're jealous or envious where conty and,
uh,
and we do not handle power,
wealth, generally speaking, fizzy,
occasional fucking Gandhi.
Um,
uh,
Ralph Nader, a Jimmy Carter. Now,
of course I got named somebody on the
rights of people don't get all comfy.
There's like this just,
okay.
I don't, I don't know enough fucking
people. I'm just saying it's very rare.
Okay. And you know what the fuck
is my phone? What the hell is it?
I hear it positive. Can you hear
it? Is it on the floor? Where is it?
Am I going to get mad at this
thing? Oh, there it is right there.
Right in front of me. Oh,
that's Versie. Or is he,
he's probably be fucking
mouth already watering.
MMM.
Yeah. So you said, well, what do you,
what do you do about it? I would, uh,
I don't know. I would just listen
to people. If they sound honest,
I would vote for them.
That's basically all you can do,
short of starting of revolution,
at which point you're going to have to,
uh, you know, be it the, the,
yeah.
I don't know if the forefront
of, uh, a lot of murder
or, you know, you can just, you know,
find love and get it to get
yourself a dog, Eh, uh, you know,
tell some jokes. I Dunno. I,
I didn't look, I try not to
think about it. It's, it's,
um,
know the way I look at it now is just
like good. Yeah. When I see shit that's,
I mean, this is, this is,
this is how I deal with the depression
of it is I just say, oh good.
When I see us doing something fucked
up. Good. Oh, that's great. You know,
there we go. That will hasten
our demise and maybe we can,
uh, maybe something else
will come along. You don't,
it was the dinosaurs were just, I dunno,
I'm not going to say they would dump,
but they were kind of just taking up space
and then when we came along, you know,
the astroid I, you asteroid
comes into web is running shit,
whatever you believe is like, all
right, let's start over again.
And it was just like an
overcorrection much in the way,
like feminism was an
overcorrection. No, it wasn't.
Feminism wasn't another correction.
What it really was was a bunch of
pussy guys who didn't, who never said,
I'll write a write that needed to be
said somewhere in the last 20 years.
They should have been a giant.
All right.
You know,
and I'll tell you right now,
believe it or not,
that's what every God damn
brought out their needs,
especially the good looking ones. All
right? And if you are an honest woman,
you know what I'm saying?
You need
a man in your life or if you gay,
you need a woman in your life to be like,
oh right.
Oh right enough.
Which is what we're fucking in.
Guys are the same way.
We like these big fucking kids
and if we don't, the same way,
if you have a kid, and I can speak
for this because I've never had one,
do you have a fucking kid and
the kid has no boundaries.
It's going to be bouncing off the
fucking walls, acting like an asshole.
And guys like me are going to be
looking at a kid and actually having the
intrusive thought of what if I just gave
that toddler an upper cut. You know,
like that's how bad the kids behave.
Like adults are the same way if
we don't have any boundaries.
That's why so many of these fucking,
these rich cons,
they got all the money in the world to
get everything they need and they still
fucked their lives. I hope
it's because, because they did.
Nobody can keep them in check.
It's kind of like when Russia fell,
when Russia fell,
that was one of the worst things
that ever happened in this country.
Russia kept us in check in that, you
know, we were sitting at grappling,
you know, we moved three feet that
way. They push us back four feet,
then we'd move five feet.
We just doing that shit.
Then once they fell down and it
was that wide open space. Yeah,
we did all the shit that we've
been doing at a, you know,
people are kind of looking at us like
we're a bunch of cops now, aren't they?
Alright. There you go. There.
Then I tied a asteroids.
Dinosaurs are in our foreign
policy without ever reading
a goddamn thing about.
How'd you like that everybody? I think
I hit new heights of ignorant. Um,
yeah,
I'm too stupid. Even. I don't know what
word comes next after that. All right.
What do we got here? Alright. What
the fuck is an excellent bill?
Our family friend,
our friend of the family and investment
banker from Yale Business School,
extremely successful,
was married about five years ago.
He was married to a bitch who went to
Harvard law school and worked as a very
successful lawyer even when
they were married. Okay.
So he's an investment banker. She, okay.
It sounds like an arranged marriage.
This is one of those things where every
day somebody in their life has on a blue
blazer anyways.
He says by themselves,
they made more money in a year
than most people make in 10 years.
That's not their fault.
They also studied hard enough to get into
Yale and Harvard or were born into it.
At which point good for
them. They got lucky. Um,
you know, you can't get mad
at people who get who, who
were born into going to Yale and Harvard.
You can't get mad at that shit unless
you are helping out people who were born
into sweatshop labor. If you were
actually helping them get out of that,
then you can get mad at that shit.
But if you're just sitting in
the middle wearing sweat shop,
labor clothes and not giving a fuck,
and you weren't born into sweatshop labor,
I don't think,
personally,
I don't think he'd get mad at someone
who's born at that blue blood shit.
See that? There's another fucking
Barbara of logic for you there anyways,
by themselves.
They made more money in a year that most
people make in 10 years when they got
divorced,
the husband got custody of the kids,
but the wife got the house and half of
every penny of the husband would ever
make for the rest of his life.
That doesn't make sense.
Let's say came, drew that up. Not only
could she now easily support herself.
She remarried another lawyer that may
just as much as her but continues to spend
the original husband's money. But as
far as I know, when she gets remarried,
the alimony stops. Yeah. Says
the child support I believe,
unless he doesn't legally adopt
them, I don't know. It's weird.
And it also goes from state to state and
I've also never read up on those laws.
People just told me
about him. Um, anyways,
she has no kids to take care of or
anything, but she's still got everything.
We live in Massachusetts, which means
the divorce laws heavily favor females,
but still, what the
fuck? Yeah, it's brutal.
I think eventually they will
be reform, uh, reformed, uh,
reformed or reformed. They
will be reformed in another
shape. They'll be reformed.
What, you know, guys, if you're still
listening to this fucking podcast, I mean,
other than beyond to just listen how
fucking stupid I am to make yourself feel
better, please don't listen
to me. Uh, yeah. I mean,
they are what? They are divorced.
Lars are what they are. And, um,
I'm done bitching about him
because I'm not doing anything.
I'm not starting a movement to try
and change him. Um, I'm a lazy fuck.
I like to sit around and complain.
But, um, if you have a petition,
I'm all about it. I'll sign it.
I'll definitely sign it. Uh,
in fairness, um, when the woman makes
more money, a guy can do that too or too.
Uh, but the way the world is set up, the
guys make most of the fucking money. So
I guess that's one of the trade offs.
So in the words of Mr Hand,
get a good one.
Fast Times at Ridgemont high referenced
to you all the people out there.
Get a good one.
Get yourself a good woman.
Um, if I ever got divorced firing, get
married and if I ever get divorced,
I'm going to tell you right now,
I am going to go into such as zen space.
I already know what the
fuck I'm going to do.
I'm going to get a one bedroom apartment.
I'm going to get an electronic drum kit
and we're gonna have a one fucking bowl,
one plate, one fork, one spoon, one knife.
I'm going to have a fucking TV and have
all the sports packages and I'm going to
dress like Malcolm Young, which is
fucking jeans, t shirt. No belt.
That's it. I'm going to ride a
bicycle and I'm just gonna. I'm just,
I'm tapping out.
I'm never going to best buy again.
I'm never going to target other than
after I get my bulk. Can you buy one ball?
I didn't think he can't.
You know
I'm going to. I will. I will. I
want you to have a vacuum cleaner.
I'll have a little broom and a dust pan
and I'm going to live like a fucking
monk. That's it. Then I'll
give her all my fucking money.
I'll keep telling jokes. I don't give a
shit. I'll give her all the fucking money.
Hey, you want it? Is this gonna
make you happy? Go ahead. Fuck it.
Fuck it. Fuck. Do I care?
You're not when it rains.
Do I get wet now? I don't
am I eating everyday? Fine.
I'm going to get into that mindset and
I'll send her that alimony and child
support check and I will draw a big
maniacal fucking smiley face on it
and uh, that's it. And I will show up.
You know what I'm going to buy? I would,
I buy a Chevy citation
with the sideways radio
and I would redo that fucker.
I'd have the ugliest fucking car on
top and underneath would be sweet.
I teach myself how to do all of that
Shit, you know? That's what I would do.
That's I was,
I already have the game plan.
Do you know this is what society
successful. You've got to,
you got to have everything all mapped out.
I'm not even married yet
and I'm still fucking, I,
I already have a plan if I
get divorced. Okay. People,
you got to think ahead. All right
friends, ugly chick, uncle Billy. Boy,
if you're a fucking divorce right now,
you want to do that rather than trying to
get all your shit back. How about this?
How about fuck heaven.
Shit not, there you go.
It's about the stupidest thing you
ever heard. But think about it.
This is a brilliance in it. Fuck
it. Why do you need to have them?
You don't need a man cave,
you know?
Then something's going to
break down and some, you know,
whatever the fuck that geek
squads got to come over there.
You don't want to deal with that shit.
I would keep it as simple to
have a banana for breakfast.
You know, take some NHL Games, but some
NBA, whatever the fuck you went to,
sit there and read the paper.
You know,
I think I'm onto something
here, right? Fuck iPods.
Get a stereo. Let's do a record.
Start churning butter. Just go,
go the other way.
Don't let her win you go the other way.
Start making your own clothes. All
right. You don't gotta go that far,
but you don't what I'm saying?
Um, anyways, friends, ugly chick.
Take a pasta, making class,
um, friends, ugly chick, Jesus.
This is going to be mean uncle Billy boy.
My friend recently got us into
his first real relationship.
This fucking broad is a
real cunt to start. Uh,
she doesn't want him hanging out with
any of his friends and basically it
doesn't let him leave the house.
Now I got to tell you something
that's complete bullshit, okay?
Okay. I agree with she doesn't want him
to hang out with any of his friends.
She could be like controlling and to,
but to say she doesn't
let him leave the house.
Is this guy literally trying to leave
the house and she's fucking putting them
in a headlock. You know, putting
them in a chicken wing or some shit.
Figure four leg lock. No.
Your friend is a pussy
with a capital p Dash.
See,
this is what now he's he,
he should be laying down the law.
He needs to be, hey, hey,
hey enough. Settle down.
Settle down.
I'm with you,
but I'm living a balanced life here.
Let me draw a circle here.
This is the time of spending with you.
This is the time I'm spending with
my friends. This is my alone time.
This is my drink and bear time.
All right.
The whole circle has to be filled with
different shit sweetheart or I'm not
going to be happy. Are you telling me
you want me to be miserable? If you are,
I am leaving for good. If you're
not, then fucking work with me.
All right?
That's what your friend needs
to say before I even get
through all this. Anyways,
goes living in Buffalo,
Buffalo.
It is rather customer to go out
once a week for chicken wings,
beer and watch some good guts watching
some goddamn hockey. Oh, by the way,
shout out to this. Say both.
They fucking own the Bruins.
It is just a regular season.
I'm not trying to jinx you
guys, but you guys, uh, you,
you're kicking our ass. I, you what
sucks is I taped the last game.
I'm not trying to avoid an ass kicking,
but you know,
for some reason I take it and I
came home and the screen was blank.
I think it was actually on the
NHL network. I take the wrong, um,
I take the wrong one, so
I actually missed it. Um,
I did read the box scores and all that
type of stuff. Uh, you know what I love?
I love how you guys keep,
I keep forgetting the guy's name,
your big six foot eight inch goon.
How you guys keep giving Bruins fan shit
that Milan Lou, Lou Cheech won't fight.
Was it John Scott? Whatever his
fucking name. What, why would,
why the fuck would you do that?
Hey,
let's have one of our best players, one
of the best power forwards in the league.
Fight a guy six foot taller than him
who weighs 50 more pounds than he does.
Six inches taller than him when a five,
six inches taller outweighs and by 40
50 pounds. And who's an absolute guru?
There's a great trade off and that we'll
have Lou Cheech who can score goals and
actually play the game.
Sit down for five minutes and
all you guys do is lose a goon.
Why would we do that? And we'll risking
having one of our best players get hurt.
Why would we do that?
That was like back in the day of Montreal.
Canadien fans would get pissed at that.
He wouldn't fight George La Rock,
you know, because he'd beat
up one of their fucking, uh,
I don't know where the fuck he beat
up. Some guy. It's, I don't know.
Someone was going to Lou Cheech
never fights anybody his size.
I click up Blue Cheech,
uh,
on youtube by searching the first guy
he's fighting as a guy his size who
actually waste more than 15 pounds.
Then him,
I'll get some guy in Toronto and
he beats the shit out of him. Okay.
Who Cheech could be your guy up,
your fucking family up and a in
something else to make three. Alright.
Stop questioning his toughness.
You can do it all you want,
but I'm not buying into it.
Hey,
how come your best guy is in fighting the
guy that we have that can't even play?
Um, anyway, so let's, let's
continue on here. Hey, by the way,
you got to go to buffalo. Fuck
Niagara Falls. You got to go to Wa.
Was it Duffy's or anchor bar?
I never,
I went to anchor bar like the one
time in history they ran out of wings.
I was at first,
he again,
we went to anchor bar first the first
night and then in the second day we would
go to a sabers game. We went
to Ankara Barn. Uh, and they,
they ran out of fucking links. So,
uh, and I got to tell you, man, they,
they make up like nobody else in
the goddamn country. Um, so anyways,
he goes, this broad won't even
let them out of the house.
I won't even let about
out once a week for that.
She has wrapped brains so badly,
warped his brains so badly that he now
thinks she's right in saying we are a bad
influence on him.
We've all been friends since early
elementary school for Christ's sake,
and she's only known
him a couple of months.
Here's where it gets fucked up. He's by
no means a bad looking guy and she looks
like she got bum rushed and was beaten
in the face with the club and for the
Cherry on top, on top,
she has her peace. Now,
how do you know that unless that
guy got up and told you, bill,
what the fuck do I do to wake him up?
Uh,
there's nothing you can do it.
There's nothing you could do.
Come on man.
This like that guy is either wired to
be submissive or he wasn't raised right.
You know,
I think a big thing, you know,
with the kid that I don't have,
the way I try to raise my
kid that I don't have is a,
I just realized I've been
leaning back and sitting forward.
So I'm sure the volume is all
over the place. I apologize. Uh,
one of the biggest things
you got to do with kids did,
you got to get them out of this shell?
You know what I mean?
Um, like I had, uh, you know,
uh, who the hell is, who
was it? One of my friends,
um, I'm trying to do this dad, I don't
like talking about people in my life.
Whatever. Somebody I knew came down.
They were wholly in the, in there, uh,
I guess right around the high school
age and they came down to New York and I
immediately, first thing I did,
I made, made him like hail a cab,
walk into a Bodega. I shown him out
of work, if you fucking get a paper,
you don't have to stand in line.
Just put a quarter down and just hold it
up and say post or whatever. Daily News,
you know,
just,
and got them immediately acclimated
into speaking up in interacting with the
fucking city and the person within like,
you know,
two days had that shit down and was like,
Oh man,
I feel like a New Yorker. And like that,
that's what you have to do with kids.
You've got to get them.
Um,
you can't have those kids that hide behind
your fucking leg would when, um, that,
you know, you're meeting
someone, this is Mr so and so,
and they're hiding behind your leg.
You can't have that.
You got it from fucking day one.
Get them out there, shake hands,
look people in the eye talk and you've,
I don't know how to do it.
Does that never had a kid.
But I think it's really important to have
to get your kid in tune with what he
or she is thinking and what he or she
wants.
Nobody wants that situation.
MMM.
And if this woman is the way
you're painting her out to be,
this is the only type of person because
she's so fucking insecure that she can
actually be with,
does she have to find
somebody so weak that mmm,
that person is going to allow them to
just completely take over their lives.
And I'll tell you what's
funny is after a while,
these controlling type of fucking people,
they ended up hating the
person that they're with.
They do because they just don't respect
them after a while. You know what I mean?
They finally got exactly what they wanted.
This person that they can use like a
fucking robot and in the end they don't
respect them.
So,
mmm.
I Dunno what I would, um, you know
what dude, this is a childhood friend.
I could tell you really wanted to guide
back. He take a shot taking it back.
MMM.
Don't say that she's ugly.
Don't mention her herpes.
It's just be like,
I mean dude,
you're literally trying to undo
this guy's hard drive at this point.
If this guy, his self esteem
is his fucking low, this
is, you know, this is like,
wait,
why the doctor Phil show sucks.
It's because somebody is going to come
in here and now this is like you're
talking about this guy. I'm guessing
it's at least in 25 years old.
You're talking about a quarter of a
century of thinking one way and then you
watch doctor Phil.
I'd be like,
you got to stick up for yourself if
you want to go out with your friends,
you got a tailor. All right,
we're going to commercial.
And like it doesn't work like that.
And also on Doctor Phil Show,
he would never do that because he would
actually be supporting the fucking guy.
Okay.
And at the end of the day it's a God damn
business and who watches that show but
a bunch of broads,
um,
yet you somehow know something about it,
don't you bill? Well, I live with a woman.
She doesn't watch him anymore.
I just can't make funding.
Make it kept making fun of how
Dr Phil looks like a crooked cop.
MMM.
I don't know. He just like,
I just not look trustworthy
to be at all. Yeah, I mean,
you know, I'm just judging them. You
don't have the same way people judge me.
It's all fair. It's all fair
in love and war. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody,
uh,
I'm actually going to go to a sports
bar here and watch the island or some
becoming a fucking island is fan.
I've been watching him lately.
Leader turning the corner.
I hated them when they were a kid
just because they were awesome.
And every time the Bruins would get the
w the one tank and we never got past the
Canadians back in the day that if we
somehow lucked out and somebody else beat
the Canadians.
This is pre 1988 we basically owned
the fucking Canadians since 1988.
I hope you guys really
realize that in Montreal.
You guys have not been a fucking
factor in our lives since 1988.
It's been great. It's been a wonderful 25
years. I know what you guys are saying.
Oh, we beat you in this playoff series
beating in that playoff series. Hey,
that shit's going to happen. We
used to never beat you. All right,
good luck with your rebuilding.
I'm just fucking with you actually like
what you guys are doing up there. Uh,
okay. What am I talking about here?
That's the podcast for this week.
Uh,
anything I have to announce,
I'm at the Wilbur theater this weekend.
Thank you everybody
for buying the tickets.
I'm going to try and give you a
heck of a show. Go yourselves.
Don't take any shit. And if you're
in a relationship like that last guy,
you need to get out of it,
you should be allowed to have friends
and go out and see the meteors crashing
into earth. All right. See you next week.